Das ist unser Fragenlotto
mit Losen für gemeine und 'netten' Fragen.
Die roten sind die gemeinen Fragen und
die grünen sind die netten Fragen! Ihr könnt wählen.
- Wir nehmen die Grünen!
Seid ihr beide ein bischen aufgedreht?
Aufgedreht?
- Ja wenn du so richtig verrückt bist.
Ja, die ganze Zeit!
Manchmal trinke ich Red Bull, nur um dieses Gefühl zu haben!
Vergesst Red Bull. Kennt ihr Michael Schuhmacher? Er hat ein neues.
Ist wie ne Droge. Es ist aber keine. Und sagt nein zu Drogen!
Das knallt so richtig. Das trinke ich immer wenn ich in Deutschland bin.
Okay, nächste Frage.
-Noch eine gemeine.
Es scheint, als seid ihr für euren Erfolg nicht vorbereit. Stimmt das?
Ja, denn für soetwas könnt ihr euch niemals vorbereiten.
Du weißt nicht, wie du eine Situation meistern sollst,
in der du noch nie zuvor warst. Wie ich sagen würde
Wurdest du jemals von nem Hai gebissen?
-Nein
Und, wie würdest du reagieren?
- Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Genau. Und wenn man mich fragt, wie man mit Erfolg umgeht - Keine Ahnung.
Okay, nächste Frage!
Wieso seid ihr so talentiert?
Ja, Yosef, wieso bist du so talentiert?
Ich denke, Talent ist etwas, was dir in die Wiege gelegt wird.
Und um das weiterzuentwickeln, musst du sehr hart arbeiten.
Wir hatten das Talent, und wir haben sehr hart dafür gearbeitet.
Also ist das eine Kombination von beidem?
Ich würde ja sagen.
Und ihr habt sehr hart gearbeitet - fast 20 Jahre!
Ja, haben wir. Meine Haare werden auch schon dünn, ich werde immer älter.
Nächste Frage.
Ist es sehr schwer in Norwegen an Drogen zu kommen?
ernsthaft. Steht das wirklich..?
Wir wissen es nicht. Deshalb dauert es auch solange zu antworten
Wir wissen es nicht!
Aber ihr seid Musiker, ihr müsst das wissen! Vielleicht nicht für euch selbst..
Ich weiß, dass es leicht ist, an Vodka, etc. zu kommen, aber ansonsten..
Ich denke nicht, dass es Drogen in Norwegen gibt!
-Okay
Nächste Frage!
okay
Interessant dass diese Frage im Nachhinein kommt
War euer Erfolg mit "Glow" wirklich nur das Ergebnis harter Arbeit
oder mehr ein Geschenk von der EBU? (European Broadcasting Union.)
Der Hintergrund ist: Es war eine große Chance für euch.
Ja. Kein Zweifel das der Eurovision Song contest eine große Chance war
Aber es war genauso verdammt harte Arbeit um reinzukommen.
Als sie unsere Version gehört haben, von dem was wir machen wollen, das ist
Schicksal. Manchmal das Universum -
- Hör auf mit so Stuss reinzureden wenn ich gerade spreche!
Manchmal kommt das Universum zusammen und die Energie geht nach innen
Es ist Schicksal.
Ich fühle...
Yosef, eine Frage an dich: Du hast den Song präsentiert und viele andere tun dasselbe.
Und du hast gewonnen! Ja, du kannst sagen, es war ein Wettbewerb in dem Sinne
und viele heiße Kandidaten hatten die Chance und sie meinten
das wir die besten wären.
- Wie wer?
Wie..Stargate Twisters, wie der "World Idol" Gewinner,
- Celine Dion Produktionen - Genau
und sie meinten das wir die besten sind um das zu repräsentieren.
Also gab es für euch einen Grand Prix vor dem Grand Prix?
- Genau!
Sehr gut ausgedrückt!
Das ist genau was passiert ist. - Gratulation
Was sind das für Fragen die die Deutschen stellen?!
Was ist die Frage?
- Ihr braucht keine Drogen, um Stoned zu sein. Oder?
auf natürliche Weise stoned!
Ja man fühlt sich gut, der Eurovision Song Contest,
Wir machen es gut. Man brauch nicht stoned zu sein.
- Ihr müsst nicht stoned sein.
okay, eine letzte Frage. Rot oder Grün?
Rot!
Okay. Glaubst du Norwegen ist ein angemessenes Land um sexuelle
Kontakte ohne Verhütung zu haben?
Neein, Das ist nicht korrekt! Ich kenn die Fragen.
Okay, glaubst du, dass Norwegen ein angemessenes Land ist, um berühmt zu werden?
Ja. Ich denke jedes Land ist dafür geeignet. Die Sache die wir in Norwegen haben
Wie nennt man das? (norwegisches Wort)
- Keine Ahnung
Das ist eine Sache über Norwegen, jeder ist gleich.
Niemand steht über jemandem, was heißt, wie wenn z.b.
Michael Jackson über die Straße läuft, die Leute werden ihn
angucken, aber es ist nicht wie hier, Bodyguards, das gibts nicht in Norwegen.
Also denken wir es ist ein guter Platz um am Boden zu bleiben,
um groß rauszukommen, ein Ort an dem du Erfolg hast.
Ist es in der USA nicht so?
Nicht leichter, aber
du wirst um einiges größer.
Also wollt ihr in die Staaten?
- Ja, wollen wir.
Wann?
In nem Monat oder zwei.
Ja, wir haben da auch gearbeitet.
-Daumen hoch. Finger kreuzen, liebe deinen nächsten, Hallo!
Vielen Dank! Und viel Glück
Danke dir.